il ne veut pas que l'on dise son nom
juste que l'on dise sa colère je suis
encore sidéré aujourd'hui en fait quand
j'en parle je comprends vraiment pas ce
qui s'est passé puis jeu ça me dépasse
de mettre une contravention et pour ça
102 dollars pour avoir refusé de
circuler sur le quai du métro depuis fin
octobre ce sont les mots qu'on entend le
plus sur le quai de berri uqam des
inspecteurs de la stm gère le flot de
passagers et depuis qu'ils sont déployés
leur comportement a fait l'objet de 45
plainte officielle et d'autres sur les
réseaux sociaux
sérieusement c'est la gestapo votre
affaire c'est vraiment agressant de se
faire beugler des ordres votre stop avec
vos gardiens qui se prennent pour des
chiens enragés
est ce que ça peut se faire de façon
différente je pense qu'on on a demandé
aux agents d'avoir un ton un peu plus
service à la clientèle plutôt que ces
révélations de la circulation a donc
c'est vers ça qu'on va aller mais
distribuer des contraventions
si les constats sont et me répond la stm
c'est que des comportements dangereux
nuisant à la sécurité ont été observés
et ce sont vraiment des cas d'exception
aussi reculé oui je vais bien je me
mettais pas en danger je mettais en
danger personne autour de moi j'en passe
et j'en paie chez personnes de circuler
de passer notamment derrière moi et
selon la photo qu'il nous a fournie
l'interpellation a eu lieu non loin du
bout du quai qu'il venait de remonter
moi ça me laisse un sentiment
d'injustice parce que j'ai pas de
voiture je paye un abonnement mensuel
douze mois par an je trouve que les
services et pas si bon que ça
les tarifs augmentent mais ils hésitent
à se lancer dans une contestation
surtout en voyant qu'une autre cause
vient de se rendre jusqu'en cour suprême
celle d'une femme qui avait eu une
contravention en 2009 pour ne pas avoir
tenu la rampe sur un escalier roulant
si mathieu prost radio canada
montréal